can I ask you a question yeah so you
said that if you date you date black
guys yeah have you ever experienced like
um where the guy's family may have made
you feel a bit uncomfortable because
you're oh okay okay
has any of you girls have any of you
girls done interracial dating
any person
I only hear everyone's experiences man
all right starting from you in the
middle yeah tell me what the the
scenario and was it a negative
experience a good experience
with me I've always
even within family like I've always been
of the preference of just African men
period because for me it's not
necessarily about all that is about
African Traditions across the board are
very similar you have different elements
because of like where you're at your
rice is the better than my rice do you
understand but it's all the same like my
um current partner now he's half
Sudanese half Kenyan and
even though I'm of a different
complexion we Bond because we have the
cultural elements there and the family
love me of my family love him off and
I've always my fingers always been that
familiarity will only ever come from
people within my continent do you
understand like I've dated
um Caribbean men
um
it's slightly different because the
culture and elements within how they are
is just quite different to African men
period and you know I've dated my own
people like I think
as long as there's that Level Playing
Field of okay there's a similar culture
you know we're kind of around the same
things you know like respecting your
elders you know we cook similar Foods we
have similar traditions we the clothing
is similar like
um languages tribes like even things
within tribes that you would never
really know unless you got into deeper
conversations aren't that far apart no
matter like where in Africa you're from
and I think because I've
been educated enough to have that
understanding I've never really had a
negative experience within that and vice
versa hey let me just say this everybody
hit the like button that at least over
half of you have not hit the like button
you are just like I don't know you're
just being weird you hit the like button
you know what I'm saying hit the like
button it helps YouTube uh push this
video out so more people can see it
there's a lot of you watching right now
yeah please help even if you're not
hitting the Super Chat and a lot of you
should hit the super chat right now even
if every one of you donates something
yeah like do something man because I'm
listen you don't really hear many of
your favorite YouTubers talking about
this kind of stuff because they're not
equipped
do you know what I'm saying so that's
what it is so do your bit hit the like
button support Super Chat all of that
good stuff all right cool
um my guy in the back yeah beard gang
yeah I want to get your take so have you
ever had any um interracial dating
experiences that were a bit off
uh yeah I mean early on in my life uh
dated
different races but I'd say the first
white girl that I went out with it was a
big shot when I first went to her house
um
it's just like here and I swear our
parents
swearing in front of their parents
things like that obviously that's
nothing that I I was used to growing up
like even just saying [ __ ] was forbidden
in my household you know what I mean so
that was massive in terms of the culture
shock um but I think when it comes to
interracial dating the main thing is
that you kind of understand each other's
culture you don't have to completely get
it but you kind of respect the main
elements of each other's culture
um and then just have similar interests
because I think culturally it doesn't
really matter too much if the culture is
exactly the same but you still need to
have similar interests like I've been
with black girls and mixed race girls
that
don't even don't know the music that I
listen to and they don't like hip-hop
music they don't like rap music they
don't know it you know I'm playing songs
in a car and they've got no idea what
I'm playing but then I could have a
white girl bring her in the car play my
music and she's rocking with it so it's
about similar interest I think modern
culture okay all right all right what
about you what have I done interracial
dates yeah yeah yeah
um I have let's let's talk about it what
was it like
um
yeah I don't I don't love it I don't
mind it like in my list of things that I
want racism
too much of a problem
um but the last white guy I spoke to he
said that I would die tired if I keep
fighting for equality and that
um the black lives matters movement is
self-righteous and
um yeah it's just not gonna happen for
us mad so that was my last
interracial Ghana
um and I haven't spoken to a white guy
since you know do you know what is mad
about that yeah I'll let you I'll go
back to you um during the BLM thing
there was some very distasteful posts I
saw on Instagram
um during the protest where
unfortunately I saw like non-black women
and there was one where she was holding
up like let's say
um
at all yeah in the shape of a man's tool
yeah and it was a black one a big black
one and she said she had something some
mad like signs saying something very
very derogatory
but it was meant to be in
um support of black men
but it was basically along the lines of
black men sexual prowess so and it was
so distasteful and it goes back to that
fact of like what beard gang said at the
back
having that respect and understanding of
culture and where people are coming from
like and that was I had an experience
like that with um a white girl that I
was seeing long time ago like years ago
and um she lived in like outside London
she's like she likes black guys right so
and sometimes you got to be beware of
that do you know what I'm saying
um and I remember one time I was trying
to explain to her like a situation like
a racial situation because I'm living in
such a white dominant environment you
get a lot of like these little niggly
situations right and I was just
explaining my frustration right and I
understand she's a white girl that's got
white family and blah blah blah but
you're meant to be on my team we're on
the same team and so boom I'm explaining
and she was like oh what are you talking
about you're just seeing things you got
a chip on your shoulder
that was the beginning of the end you
know what I'm saying because you you
just don't you just don't see outside of
your bubble to get them saying that but
then on the other hand I've been
involved with um non-black women who do
understand but they tend to be the ones
that are from like Multicultural
environments they've grown up with black
people are black friends yeah she's good
she's got black friends do you get what
I'm saying so there's levels in it
there's levels here but current did you
have more
um no that was really it like yeah I've
not dated anyone that's not black since
okay tell me about your interracial
dating experiences did you is it all
been love and rainbows and sunshine or
has it been has there been any
stereotypical episodes or anything what
no I always said like good relationships
with my exes I just have to say that I
prefer to date black men because I think
our cultures much more because where are
you from again I'm from Portugal okay
and I grew up in an area there's a lot
of black people like from Angola Cape
Verde Mozambique
um so I feel like I've dated a white a
white British guy and I feel me being a
white person but not from England our
cultures didn't match
so that's why like I can relate more
with being a black guy and I feel like
and he was asking about like families
and stuff I feel like they are very
welcoming I never had any issues with
like going to a black ice house and
seeing their moms whatever and they were
all like very nice to me very welcoming
yeah very welcoming yeah definitely I
and I think I feel like you know some
people may disagree but I feel like
black people we're actually quite
welcoming yeah
whereas again as I said earlier I feel
like other groups may be a little bit
more cautious of black cause of what
they've seen on Grime daily yeah I'm
saying they say they got Grime daily but
I'm just saying this is an example yeah
but I'm just saying like what what has
been portrayed by music and movies but
anyway um did you have something you
want to say
the novel you got assigned to say to
let's hear about your interracial dating
experience gone so I'm mixed race which
means that actually most people that I
will date are likely to be in an
international relationship with me so
I've been I think okay we've got a
unique experience have you yeah because
it's interesting because I I'm black but
I'm not black right I'll explain I've
been with um I've had white boyfriends
their family loved me why because
I could relate to them I know how to
kind of be within that environment
because that's also kind of part of what
I know because my mom's also white and
they like the exoticness they like oh
spicy they love a little bit of a cha
cha cha something different you know
then on the other side
um with the black guys black guys that
I've actually dated on Nigerians I don't
know it's my curse or my blessing I'm
not sure yet uh so far obviously anyway
and I feel like with them I met with a
little bit more resistance sometimes
because I think there's a suspicion of
who is this kind of watered-down person
that is African but the mother is white
do you go I mean so
it can be a lot of pressure actually
because I'm going into a family or
somebody that is nearly that like that
should relate to them but they're not
sure so I think I've struggled more with
the black side and like of dating than
with the white side in terms of meeting
families in terms of merging with
culture I would definitely black men
emerge better with the black man than
with the white man because I think that
I'm too spicy and too exotic and too
different and too energetic and just I
don't you are a bit much [ __ ] much at
times though I I don't think that's
going on to do no I think that's just
you no it yeah I think he has to
definitely do with the the white man
them still because it's like they don't
get me they don't get me they I think
sometimes like white men also fantasize
a lot about the idea of having a black
woman you know and if your light skin is
even easier because you're not full
black oh can I add a little caveat to
that
um
when what I've noticed especially with
like white girls yeah a lot of times
when they say they like black guys a lot
of times they mean mixed race and and a
lot of times when white boys say they
like black girls they mean mixed race
yeah to get on saying like it's easier
pill to swallow yes this is more of a
yeah oh yeah I love black girls man yeah
she's mixed race bro
do you remember this is just taking it
back to just something that we were
talking about before do you remember
that kind of that group chat
um video that came out of the white girl
some people said that it was fake though
mind you though I don't think that it's
fake I I don't know if it I don't know I
did a video about it a long time ago
when it when it happened I don't know I
don't know I'm just saying but I think
that that could that could very much be
uh something that happens in real life
I'm not saying that thing I'm not saying
that thing specifically is real but I
can believe that right do you understand
like that's not no far-fetched think do
you get what I'm saying
um okay cool oh God bro
so I think it's so I think first off all
the women that I've dated
they they worked in Black communities
and they were receptive so
they need so like for example one girl I
dated she came back to the hood my
grandma's rolling a blunt drinking
Budweiser 76 we're watching um
literally oh they're robbing the Rite
Aid and we're just sitting on the porch
because that's what happens in the hood
and she's there
and I have a friend who's married to a
white girl and I think don't
underestimate these women because some
of them are really about it and then
again men are
it's kind of like the Dowry or the bride
price so the woman
because she was in the hood she can tell
her parents and get the parents up to
speed and the parents they only care
about their daughter has a man that
could support her that's the only thing
they care about so they don't care that
I'm black they just care that her
daughter has a supporter and then in
terms of other things women from other
races their parents have more money
their parents will pay for private
school they have more resources so
they're like okay he's paying everything
for my daughter
if you take care of all our bills they
are going to step in in a certain way so
I think it will never be a cultural fit
100 but I think there are certain things
that play play into this
um and make it at least palatable for
black guys but it's I mean it's never
perfect I do think most of the time it's
you know you're you're kind of settling
for
the non-black person at least it might
like that's how I feel as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible